Music Das Prat-Gerisgau. Fade out. Herzlich willkommen zur neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO DPU. Den mag ich besonders gern. Nicht mit Stefan F., nicht mit Stefan D., sondern mit Stefan T. Er ist im Raum, Schön, dass du da bist. Und kein Gehör als Florentin. Ach was. Pascal, David, Will, David Pascal, David Brecht, Richard ist mit mir dabei. Ich möchte dir ganz herzlich dich beglückwünschen zu 188 Folgen. Heute ist Folge 188, ein bisschen die Nazi-Folge, wenn man ehrlich ist. 1-8-8 und 8-8.
Also mal gucken, welche Zuhörer wir heute kriegen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das verraten darf.
Bist du Nazi-Gemot?
Nee, aber eine Netflix-Redakteurin von uns wurde offensichtlich am 4.5.88 geboren und heisst bei Instagram ihr Name 4588. Es hat, also wir hatten einen schwierigen Start mit ihr, muss man sagen. Kann man nicht mehr vorstellen. Und irgendwann haben wir ihr es dann einfach gesagt, dass das nicht funktioniert. Du kannst im Internet nichts heißen mit dem Suffix 4588. Nee, es funktioniert einfach nicht. 4588 ist schlimm, ist nicht schlimm, minde schlimmste Zahlenkombination. Weil ich habe mal so einen Post gesehen, der super geliked wurde, viraler Post von irgendeinem T-Shirt Manufaktur, wo man so Custom T-Shirts machen kann und jemand wollte für seinen Geburtstag, den ersten 8.88. Und und die haben dann so einen grossen Post gemacht so von wegen ja das kam rein und wir haben rausgegeben so ein T-Shirt wo ganz gross drauf steht die fascist und das haben sie geschickt weil sie dachten eins acht und so wie Überraschungspartner genau das ist für dich die fascist wir haben extra für dich ein T-Shirt gemacht, nur für dich, die Faschist. Danke. Es ist schwierig, die Faschist. Noch lustiger wäre das, wenn er willig Faschist gewesen wäre. Ja, schon, ja. Und am 1.8.88 geborene Women denkt so, Jackpot einfach. Ja, das ist doch schon geil. Und du könntest dir was tätowieren lassen und immer sagen, nee, was ist mein Geburtsdatum? Das ist wie ein Star-Wars-Fan, am 4.5. geboren zu sein. Weil man einfach sagt so, yes, einfach perfekt. Ich habe letztens auch gehört, wo jemand nicht wusste, ob er eingreifen soll oder nicht. Es gibt ja oft so Situationen im Leben, du siehst was und du weißt nicht, ist das jetzt ein Theaterstück, ist das jetzt ein Film, wo ist die Kamera, ist das jetzt Prank, ist das jetzt moderne Kunst?
Oder ist es das Leben, ist es dann doch das Leben.
Oder ist es das Leben, ist es wirklich eine Gewalttat, die da verübt wird, soll ich eingreifen? Und jemand hat ein T-Shirt getragen mit der Aufschrift NSDAP. Okay, ich finde das deswegen so lustig, weil oft gibt es ja so Codes, versteckte Codes und dann gibt es ja diese Marke, wo man so die Jacke so drüber trägt, sodass in der Mitte noch was übrig bleibt. Ah ja ja, Lonsdale? Ja genau, wo dann NS in der Mitte stehen bleibt oder sowas. Es gibt ja diese ganzen elaborierten Codes, aber der dachte sich, fuck it, all in, einfach all in, all in, good old NSDAP. Er hat es nicht verstanden wahrscheinlich. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Er hat die Codes, die Elaborierten Codes nicht verstanden, er hat gesagt, ich traue einfach, ich gucke mal, wann NSDAP schon drucken, man kann sich schon drucken, man muss nicht das nehmen, was es schon gibt und das verduschen. Ja, und das ist auch die Frage, was spricht man den anderen und sagt, also weil man kommt ja nicht weit, man kann ja nicht sagen, du, das war echt eine scheisse Zeit. Und er sagt, ja, jetzt wo ich nochmal drüber nachgedacht habe, war echt nicht so NSDAP. Ja, ich dachte jetzt eher für die Umweltpolitik und so, aber du hast schon recht, die Krieg und so war scheiße. Hast mich überzeugt. Nee, wer so offensiv dieses Shit-Hur-Track trägt, ist es vor allem auch nicht wie bei 4-5-8-8, wo man sagt, da ist jemand mit naiven Optimismus durch Netz spaziert. Nein, da ist einfach jemand offensiv ein Wichser. Ja, oder vielleicht ist es so ein Startup, irgendwie so Natural Anthology, Society. Natural National Security. Genau, und einfach so, Sekunde mal, jetzt haben wir schon die T-Shirts gedruckt. Ja, schwierig. Würdest du da Zivilcourage zeigen, würdest du da eingreifen und den wegtacklen? Ja, macht's wie ich neuerdings und ruft immer die Polizei.
Denn ich habe neulich mal die Frage gestellt, wann ruft man eigentlich die Polizei und sollte man nicht schon bei einem leeren Kinderwagen die Polizei rufen? Ja. Es kamen sehr viele Nachrichten. Ja, ich habe auch Nachrichten bekommen. Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen von jemandem, der die Plakatkampagne der Polizei Hamburg abfotografiert hat, wo die offensiv dafür geworben haben, dass man doch bitte einfach durchklingeln soll. Ja, immerame Polizisten, ruft mal an. Single-Frauen und Männer ruft die Polizei Hamburg an. Kurz durchklingeln. Einfach mal kurz, egal was ist. Vor allem so abends zwischen 23 und 24 Uhr, einfach mal kurz, hallo. Wenn es dunkel wird und ich einsam bin, ruft doch mal kurz durch. Ist nicht Notruf wirklich ein extrem langweiliger Job meiste Zeit? Weil ich meine, es muss ja mehr... Ich glaube, das ist eine spannende Provokation, weil man würde ja eigentlich behaupten, dass es der aufregendste Job ist. Ja, aber ich meine, es muss ja, wenn ja gleichzeitig zehn Leute anrufen, dann müssen ja zehn Leute da sitzen, die den Anruf annehmen. Das heißt, es müssen in der Regel mehr Leute da in dem Büro sitzen, als Anrufe reinkommen. Also hast du immer zehn, die nichts machen den ganzen Tag. Da frage ich mich auch, ich war gestern beim Eishockey, deswegen beziehe ich jetzt alles wieder aufs Eishockey, weil das ist mein Thing. Das ist ja die nächste Phase. Nein, nein, nein, nein, es ist nur wie mein Gehirn funktioniert. Aber beim Eishockey kommt ja erst die beste Starting Six aufs Feld und dann tauschen die die ganze Zeit durch. Ja, bis die Kinder dran. Bis irgendwann die B-Jugend dran ist. Was ich mir frage, ist die erste Person, die immer drangeht, die beste Person? Ja. Ist es die erste Person, die abnimmt in der Notrufzentrale Hamburg? Ist das der beste Fragenbeantworter, Notrufannehmer oder Annehmerin?, wie teilen Sie sich da auf? Ich stelle mir immer so vor, dass wenn jemand anruft, so der ganze Raum rot blingt und du du du und ich so du bist dran. Und dann sich direkt der Chef so dazustellt und so mithört und sagt, geh ran, geh ran, geh ran und sich so an den Tisch lehnt. Ja, hallo, hier ist was in meiner Wohnung, ja, ja, was, was? Frag ihn, frag ihn, was, frag ihn, was, was, frag ihn, was. Hier ist ein riesiger Storch in meiner Wohnung, er ist bekifft. Ja, gut. Gut, Pauli! Und dann schreibt jemand so ein grosses, macht dann so einen Strich durch die vier Kiffer, die schon angerufen haben. Ja, paranoide Kiffer. Vaddam. Ja, genau. Ich glaube auch, dass manche nur mal blockiert sind mit Sicherheit, weil die zu häufig anrufen. Das stimmt, ja. Hören Sie auf, hier anzurufen. Das stimmt. Ist das wie bei Gesichtern, wenn du in Läden verboten bist, hängt ja manchmal dein Gesicht, also mein Gesicht hängt in sehr vielen Läden, deswegen komme ich nicht mehr rein, an vielen Spielplätzen auch, hängt mein Gesicht. Deswegen lässt sich das auf dem Schnurrbart wachsen. Deswegen lässt sich das auf dem Schnurrbart wachsen. Aber es ist dann auch so bei Nummern, die an einem Rand stehen, so Fotos von Telefonnummern, und dann weiss man direkt, nee, da soll man nicht reingehen. Wenn der eine von diesen Nummern wiedererkennt, dann geht nicht ran. Ich habe ja einmal in einem Callcenter gearbeitet und da gab es auch so eine Blacklist, so Nummern und Leute, die wenn anrufen, sofort abgewürgt werden sollen. Aber da ging es nicht um das normale Alltagsgeschäft, sondern direkt, weil ich war auch so eine Art Sekretär für meinen Chef. Also wenn Leute anrufen und ihn sprechen wollen, muss ich sagen.
Also alle seine Ex-Frauen.
So und dann anrufen und dann wurde ich eingelernt und als Einlerner bist du ja wirklich nichts.
Und so, das ist ein Telefon und das musst du desinfizieren. Ja, ja, okay.
Und das ist die Liste von Leuten, wenn die anrufen, dann sofort abwimmeln.
Und ich schaue auf diese Liste und ganz oben steht in ganz grossen Buchstaben Mama The New York Times. Und ich dachte mir, was? So ein runtergekommenes Callcenter, wo irgend so ein Typ versucht, mit fadenscheinigen Kontaktanzeigen ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen. The New York Times. Entweder, also Theorie eins, Theorie eins, weißt du das Ergebnis eigentlich? Nein, gar nicht. Nie nachgefragt. Theorie eins, die machen ein Investigativstück über ihn, weil die einen grossen Ring aus Pseudo... Was amerikanische Leser vor allem interessiert, ist ein Münchner kleinen Geschäftsmann. Naja, wenn es ein internationaler Verbrecherring ist, glaube ich doch, dass es die New York Times-Leser interessiert.
Weiß ich nicht.
Sie sind ja offen für kulturelle internationale Sachen. Das ist die Theorie 1. Theorie 2. Er hat ein Abo nicht bezahlt. Er hat ein Abo nicht gekündigt und nicht bezahlt. Und hat Milliarden Euro Schulden, Dollar. Ja, oder Theorie drei, dass er einfach diese Liste sich angeschaut hat, Tante Doris, Pauli und die Zeugen Jehovas. Und er sich dachte, die Liste braucht noch was. Nee, die sagt nicht das aus über mich, was ich will, dass es aussagt. Machen wir noch CIA. Ja, okay, okay, eins runter. The New York Times. Und tatsächlich habe ich mir, weil ich keine Ahnung, war damals so eingeschüchtert, dass ich mir wirklich dachte, scheiße, wie erkenne ich jetzt die New York Times, wenn die anruft, vielleicht sprechen die dann so krasses Englisch und ich erkenne die nicht. Und was ist, wenn jetzt irgendwie Newsweek anruft und ich es dir für die New York Times halte? Oder die Washington Post. Ja, und ich dachte, ich bin hier in so einem internationalen. Es ist fast die New York Times. Ich dachte, ich bin hier so ein internationalen, ich habe hier mit globalen Geschäftspartnern, nee, haben nur Rentner angerufen, die nicht lesen konnten, was sie genau eintippen müssen in ihrem Scheißtelefon. Ich habe eine Idee, wir rufen da jetzt an und sprechen Englisch und sagen, wir sind von der New York Times. Wirklich, und dann will ich mal sehen, wie abgewimmelt wird. Wie gut der Typ angelernt ist, der Nachfolger ist.
Gibt es die Firma noch? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die Firma noch gibt.
Also als ich da saß, wie gesagt, das war so ein riesiges
Callcenter-Büro
mit bestimmt 20, 30
Schreibtischen. Aber wie groß ist denn die Chance, dass bei dir
der New York Times-Ansuch durchkommt?
Das ist es nämlich, wollte ich gerade sagen, 20, 30 Schreibtische,
alle leer.
Nur einer ist besetzt, wo man merkt,
okay, Kontaktanzeigen,
Anrufe waren mal eine grössere
Sache, jetzt aber nicht mehr.
Das heißt, es war eine Branche, die
stirbt. Ich war in der sterbenden Branche
Kontaktanzeigen per Telefon
zugange, wo man sofort in diesen Raum
reinkommt und merkt, die machen es noch zwei, drei Wochen.
In einem Meeting ist auch der legendäre
Satz gefallen, wir hätten
das damals mit dem Internet machen sollen.
Ah, okay, wow. Aber diesen Satz habe ich nie mehr in meinem Leben mitbekommen. Das hat mich noch gefreut. In einer Zeit arbeiten, wo der Satz noch fällt. Wobei ich war in einer Lokalzeitung, die an dich gemacht hat. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann mir vorstellen, in den Meetings war ich dann nicht, weil es so unwichtig, aber wahrscheinlich ist der Satz auch gefallen. Wir hätten mehr mit diesem Internet machen sollen. Ja, gerade so so so Dating-Angebote und so ist ja klar, dass das natürlich über das Internet läuft, obwohl ja viele Rentner dabei waren, die noch für die Zeitung geziehen und so. Von daher hat man wahrscheinlich die Abwägung gemacht, wie lange gibt es dieses Business überhaupt noch, also wie lange können wir überhaupt noch konkurrieren, bis es einfach Tinder übernimmt, Tinder für Rentner. Rentner, heißt aber einfach Rentner, weil so ähnlich klingt wie Tinder. Ich glaube, das ist mit das Unangenehmste, was deine Freundin auf deinem Handy finden kann, ist nicht Tinder oder Grindr, sondern Rentner. Die Rentner-Dating-App. Und die Flamme, das ist auch die Flamme von Tinder, aber kleiner. So halb aus. Aber kleiner, ist quasi aus. Man sieht schon den Docht sehr gut. Ja, so Rauchschwaden noch. Das Feuer ist aus. Geist. Und der Geist, der so hochkommt. Das Feuer ist, die Flamme ist erloschen. Ich kann mal gucken, ich glaube, ich habe hier kein Internet, aber ich kann mal schauen, ob es die Firma noch gibt überhaupt. Jetzt müssen wir einen rauspiepen. Es gab gestern auf diesem Eishockey-Videowürfel oben in der Arena, gab es Werbung für eine App, wo ich dachte, die App schliesst sich allein durch das Medium, was es ist, der Zielgruppe komplett aus. Es verwehrt sich der Zielgruppe, weil es war eine App für Leute, die sehr viele Medikamente nehmen, die sich daran erinnern, wann sie welche Medikamente nehmen, eine Medikamenten-App, wo ich dachte, aber entweder du nimmst Medikamente, aber dann bist du noch auf der geistigen Höhe, also entweder du hast Pfleger oder du bist nicht mehr in der geistigen Verfassung und dann müssen es Leute für dich machen. Aber wer, der auf geistiger Höhe ist, benutzt denn eine App, um seine Medikamentendosierung zu bewachen? Ja. Weil das ist doch sehr wichtig. Das kann man sich auch mal merken dann vielleicht. Oder du bist einfach sehr alt und hast kein Smartphone. Smartphone.. Wer ist die Zielgruppe dieser Medikamenten-App? Also eine super elaborierte, dann haben die auch so Ausstattung gezeigt, wie diese App aufgebaut ist. Das ist super komplex, so Excel-artig, wann man welche Medikamente nehmen sollte. Also Herr Tietze, Sie kriegen hier dieses Fläschchen Medikamente und dann nehmen Sie jeden Tag eine. Okay, ja, das riecht. Okay, jeden Tag eine. Okay, das rieche ich.
Okay, jeden Tag eine.
Ja, das rieche ich.
Sind 40 Pillen drin, sollten also reichen für?
40 Tage.
Wunderbar, alles klar, dann sehen wir uns in 40 Tagen wieder.
Alles klar.
Wiedersehen.
Gut.
Zwei Tage später.
Ich habe meine Tabletten vergessen.
Das Podcast-Ufo Werbung. Brauchen Sie eine neue App? Irgendeine? Völlig egal welche, Sie haben diese eine Lücke in Ihrem Startscreen, wo Sie denken, da gehört noch eine App hin. Da gehört noch eine App rein. Dann laden Sie doch die App rein. Dann laden Sie unsere App. Wir wissen nicht, an wen wir uns sonst wenden sollen, ausser an Leute. Das ist unsere, wir haben Marktforschung betrieben und herausgefunden, unsere grösste Zielgruppe sind Leute mit App-Lücken. Alle anderen nehmen entweder Tabletten und sind auf der geistigen Höhe. Bevor sie gar keine runterladen, haben sie doch einfach unsere runter. Das ist kostenlos. Naja, die ersten zwei Monate. Dann muss man richtig viel zahlen. Ja, das ist eine verwirrende App. Hast du denn mal geschaut, ob es die Firma noch gibt? Ja, ich komme hier gar nicht ins Internet rein. Ich bin hier ohnehin so ein bisschen aus allem rausgestückelt worden. Aber ich habe tatsächlich auch Nachrichten bekommen, und zwar von einer Polizistin. Und die hat geantwortet auf meine Bedenken, a zum Thema Geldwäsche. Ja, und ich habe ja... Boah, aber sorry. Nee, nee, nee. Das ist mit unserer Webseite, das kriegt keiner mit. Du kannst in meiner Gegenwart nicht in Satz mit den Worten begehen, da hat die Polizistin sich bei mir gemeldet. So, und zwar, ich habe ja erzählt, dass ich mein Auge auf dem Supermarkt habe, wo ich denke, dass Geld gewaschen wird. Und ich habe erzählt, dass ich mal gesehen habe, wie nachts in der Hinterhofgasse zwei Herren die Nummernschilder ihrer Autos getauscht haben. Welcher Spur ist sie nachgegangen? So, sie hat gesagt, vergiss die Geldwäsche, vergiss es, lass es, vergiss es. Hat sie einen Grund genannt oder war es mehr so Selbstschutz? Sie hat gesagt, na ja, manchmal weiss man ja nicht genau, wie das funktioniert und so wie im Fernsehen läuft es halt auch manchmal nicht. Sie hat durch die Blume gesagt, du hast keine Ahnung, wovon du redest und du hast es grundsätzlich nicht verstanden und lass es einfach verschwenden dich deiner Zeit. Aber das schwingt auch mit, ich weiss auch nicht genau, wovon ich rede, weil manchmal läuft es nicht so wie im Fernsehen. Vielleicht, ich weiss im Fernsehen, ist mir zu vage, um die Spur fallen zu lassen. Sie hat aber gesagt, ja generell jederzeit anrufen und vor allem das mit den Nummernschildern, meinte sie, das wäre generell ein schlechtes Zeichen, da kann man anrufen. Also wenn ihr in der Öffentlichkeit seht, wie Nummernschildern getauscht werden von Autos, ruft die Polizei und sagt, Hashtag Podcast UFO, ich habe ein Podcast UFO davon gehört, müsst ihr Werbung machen, und dass ich jetzt hier anrufen soll. Kennen Sie den Podcast? Ich möchte Gutscheincode einlösen und dann einfach sagen, kommt hier mal vorbei mit euren Pferden. Ich möchte bitte nur die Pferde. Kann man eigentlich auch sagen, wovon man gerettet werden möchte? Oh ja, das finde ich eine spannende Frage. Ich habe hier einen Bär in meiner Wohnung, bitte bringt die Pferde! Der Streifenwagen ist auf dem Weg. Nein, ich will die Pferde! Ich will die Segway-Polizisten und diesen grossen Leiterwagen. Ich wohne im Erdgeschoss, aber ihr könnt den... Herr Tietze, das ist die Feuerwehr, das machen wir nicht. Ja, aber ihr könnt doch mit Bären in der Wohnung... Das ist die Feuerwehr. Wir haben mit der Feuerwehr nichts zu tun. Ja, aber so ein Leiterwagen ist halt irgendwie ... Wir schicken zwei Streifenwagen vorbei, okay? Zwei? Ja. Dann wenigstens drei. Gut, drei. Aber dieser ... Udo! Bumm! Ja, es gibt schon ... Aber das stimmt, man will die Pferde. Man will immer die Pferde. Ich habe heute das Lustigste der Welt gehört. Ja, ja mal gucken, ob das standhält, der Mann einer Kollegin hat ein Kind auf dem Arm gehabt und ist über eine rote Ampel gegangen. Aber er ist auch gebürtiger New Yorker, von daher kann man machen. Man geht über rote Ampel in New York, beziehungsweise da ist ja Orangenampel und die werden dann irgendwann weiss.
Ist eine andere Stadt, kann man machen. Man geht über rote Ampeln in New York, beziehungsweise da ist ja orangene Ampel und die werden dann irgendwann weiß. Ist eine andere Stadt, ist so wild da drüben. In Deutschland wird es ja dann rot und grün und er ist mit rote Ampel mit seinem Kind auf der Schulter gelaufen und so. Und dann hat uns ein Polizist gesehen, der natürlich, wie es sich für einen richtig deutschen Polizisten gehört, ausgeflippt ist und gesagt hat, hey, das kann nicht sein. Und ihr Mann hat einfach versucht, das wegzuignorieren und ist einfach weggegangen in der Hoffnung, dass er das sein lässt. So wie man das in New York macht, wenn die Polizei was sagt, dann ignoriert man das. Ignoriert man das dann. Und dann, ich nehme mir vor, wenn man das in der amerikanischen Schule lernt, bei deutschen Polizisten, totstellen oder einfach taubstellen. Und der Polizist stand aber jetzt in dem Zwiespalt, dass er das blöd fand und am liebsten noch ahnden würde, aber ja an der roten Ampel stand und wegen der Tochter auf dem Arm ein gutes Beispiel sein wollte und ihn nicht mehr erreicht hat, weil die Ampel rot war. Und ich fand er so schön deutsch. Und ich st mir vor, wie lustig wär's eigentlich, wenn in Deutschland alle Schwerverbrecher, Rapists, Mörder, Bankräuber, alle nicht gefasst werden, weil die deutschen Polizisten nicht über Rot fahren. Die Polizei einfach an der roten Abwürdig. Wir wissen nicht, was wir machen sollen, aber wir können doch nicht über Rot fahren. Ich find das nicht lustig, weil er konnte es sich nicht übers Herz bringen, einfach über Rot zu gehen. Rudi, gib Gas, hier ist 30, hier ist nur 30, die fahren weg! Hier ist nur 30, hier ist nur 30, der fährt 100, das kann er doch nicht machen, nee, da hast du recht, das kann er nicht machen. Und das Problem war aber, der Polizist war so sauer trotzdem darüber und hat dann ganz doll gerufen, sie Dummkopf. Nein, das kann man nicht machen. Sie Dummkopf, hat er gesagt. Das ist Strafgeld. Für den Polizist war aber so sauer trotzdem darüber und hat dann ganz doll gerufen, sieh Dummkopf. Nein, das kann man nicht machen. Sieh Dummkopf, hat er gesagt. Das ist Strafgeld. Für den Polizisten? Ja, klar. Dummkopf sind 60 Euro. Dummkopf? Dummkopf sind 60 Euro. Dummbatz? Ja, Dummbatz geht, aber Dummbatz geht? Ja, Dummbatz ist kindlich freundlich. Arschloch? Aber nee, auf gar keinen Fall, 160 Euro. Dödel? 220 Euro. Idiot. Vier Jahre Gefängnis. Also Dummkopf gesagt. Und seitdem hat die Tochter Angst vor Polizisten, weil sie denkt, weil das war die erste Erfahrung mit einem deutschen Polizisten für das amerikanische Kind. Und die sind natürlich jetzt total traumatisiert, weil sie denkt, Polizisten sagen Dummkopf, beleidigen Leute einfach. Und sie hat kein Vertrauen zu Polizisten, was glaube ich schon einschneidend sein kann.
Das heißt, der Polizist wollte ein gutes Beispiel sein und ist in der Ampel stehen geblieben sogar, hat dann aber den Vater und das Kind beleidigt. Schwierig, finde ich. Es ist super schwierig. Ich stelle mir eh vor, dass es als Polizist immer so diese Autorität zu wahren und immer so dieses Bild nach außen zu geben, dieses Vorbild und dein Freund und Helfer, wenn man einfach auch, keine Ahnung, irgendwie einfach sich mit Ketchup bekleckert hat und man denkt, ich bin nicht besser als ihr. Nee, genau. Ihr seid vielleicht besser als ich? Das ist Blut, das ist kein Ketchup. Ich habe jemanden erschossen. Achso, okay. Ich dachte, schon, sie wären voll Idiot. So, Florentin tippt ganz aufgeregt schon in seinen Computer. Ist die Frage, ob investativ Florentin herausgefunden hat, ob es sie noch gibt. Oh, Öffnungszeiten geöffnet, schliesst um 21 Uhr. Oh, da haben wir noch Zeit. Dann haben wir ja jetzt Zeit. Gut, genau. Zeit. Ich tipp die Nummer ein. Warum denn mein Handy jetzt?
Weil die meins kennen.
Weil du auch bei der Blockettliste stehst.
Das weiss ich nicht.
Okay, aber du musst auf laut machen natürlich, ne?
Und du musst Englisch sprechen.
Hallo, das ist Florentin from the New York Times.
Ne, wir rufen beide an.
This is Steve and Florian from the New York Times. Was ruf man denn da an? Hey, was ruf man da an? Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden, was die Idee ist für diesen Callcenter.
Lieber Anrufer, leider sind you are from the New York Times, please fuck yourself and don't ever call again, never call again, don't ever, don't even think about calling again. So, jetzt hast du die Nummer, nicht, dass ich hier weiter Saft versauere hier. Nee, ich würde das gleich nochmal anrufen. Warum ruft man da genau da an? Was ist das für eine Agentur? Ja, das möchte ich jetzt nicht genau sagen. Nee, ich verstehe schon, du musst es ja nicht genau sagen. Aber grob, Kontaktanzeigen. Ja, also verschiedene Sachen, so Zeitungsgewinnspiele und so ein Crap. Ich will jetzt echt nicht zu viel sagen, weil sonst... Okay. Weil ich musste da auch... Das war halt wirklich mit... Man musste Sachen unterschreiben, dass man nichts... Aber das ist bestimmt alles abgelaufen und so. Das ist auch egal. Aber die Polizistin meinte auch so, lass das mal mit der Geldwäsche, das ist nix. So als die Bürgerpflicht, also so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist mehr weist uns mal auf konkrete Dinge hin. So hier hat jemand eine Waffe in der Hand, hier ist ein schreiendes Kind, das keine Mutter hat, sowas. Hier wird Geldwäsche betrieben. Ja, aber das ist ja nichts so akutes, so, also sie, ich habe viermal nachgefragt, ja, Moment mal, aber ich habe konkrete Beweise und sie hat immer wieder gesagt, lass es mal, sowas, das bringt nichts. Oder es sind laufende Ermittlungen, das glaube ich ja. Oder sie hängt da mit drin, das ist ja, die Polizisten hängen ja immer halt mit drin, Mensch, jetzt haben wir da was, jetzt haben wir da was. So ist es doch. Aber ich dachte mir, ich dachte clever, clevere Beobachtung auch, Dinge, die sehr, sehr lange haltbar sind. Ja. Bis ich gemerkt habe, dass es ja auch Dinge gibt, die immer haltbar sind und niemals ablaufen, wie zum Beispiel T-Shirts. Ich war nämlich jetzt in einem Laden in Köln, habe ich entdeckt, da hat jemand verkauft, das ist ein Modeladen, wo jemand drin arbeitet, der offensichtlich keine Ahnung von Mode hat. Ich bin da reingegangen, weil das sah so schick aus, war so ein minimalistischer Laden. Das sind zwei Sätze hintereinander, die einfach perfekt passen. Ja, ich bin da rein, weil der Laden war schön, hat mir gefallen. Die hatten drei Shirts im Schaufenster, ich dachte, das ist ein minimalistischer Laden. Die hatten nur auch ganz rein weisse Shirts und rein schwarze Shirts. Eigentlich genau das, was man noch will. Basic Shirts. Und die sahen ganz schick aus, bin ich da rein und die hatten nur das. Und dann bin ich, und der hatte keine Ahnung von nichts. Und diese Shirts waren ganz seltsam, die waren so viel zu eng auch. Also selbst die grösste L war keine grösste L, also es war hauteng, wie so ein Neoprenanzug, ganz, ganz hauteng. Alles daran war falsch, und dann bin ich rausgegangen und dachte mir, hm, das ist ein cleverer Geldwäscheladen. Shirts, teure Shirts, der kann nicht überleben, dieser Laden kann nicht überleben, wie soll der Laden überleben? Aber ist nicht gerade Mode sehr zeitabhängig, also sehr ablaufbar? Ab? Ja, aber du willst es ja nicht verkaufen. Also die Mode ändert sich doch alle sechs Monate, wenn ich da in die Fachzeitschrift. Aber du willst es ja nicht verkaufen. Ja, aber fällt es der Polizei nicht auf, wenn da Mode ist, die Modegeschäfte, wo die Mode total aus der Mode ist? Sagt man doch nicht, Moment mal, Rita. Nee, das ist die Modepolizei, von der du gerade sprichst. Zugriff, deswegen haben die ja eine Modepolizei. Aber es stimmt schon, im Grunde könnte jeder Laden Geldwäscheladen sein. Ich glaube, das wollte ich damit sagen, lass es einfach. Ich bleibe da dran, ohne Witz, ich bleibe da dran. Ich habe auch genau eine Liste von Leuten, die da ab und zu reingehen. Hast du ein Foto gemacht? Ich habe schon Fotos gemacht und nachher habe ich sie auch gefragt, weil das fand ich nämlich ein interessantes Thema, inwiefern darf man verdächtige Leute filmen? Weil angenommen, die machen jetzt diesen Nummernschildaustausch, darf ich das filmen, weil das ist ja gegen deren Persönlichkeitsrechte und so und ich habe die nicht gefragt und es darf man ja nicht einfach so und es ist aber mit guter Intention, sondern ich will das als Beweismaterial haben und sie meinte ja, wenn ich das jetzt nicht an meine Freunde verschicke oder irgendwie selbstständig damit irgendwas mache, sondern es direkt an die Polizei gebe, dann ist es okay. Dann kann man auch im Vorhinein Dinge filmen, wo man noch nicht genau weiß, ob das tatsächlich jetzt relevant ist oder nicht. Interessant. Ja, das ist spannend. Ich finde auch echt schwierig, dass es am Handy keine Lampe hinten gibt, die indiziert, dass du gerade filmst. Das finde ich wirklich interessant. Gibt es hier auch Länder, wo das, ich glaube in Japan oder so. Ja, das kannst du ja einfach abkleben, oder? Also ich, wenn du jetzt wirklich schön in den Ups gehörten, in den Urbana. Aber das ist doch auch super auffällig. Ich sag nur, das wäre ja auch auffällig, wenn du das abklebst. Nee, dann kannst du ja eine Handyhülle machen, dass da kein Loch hat. Ich habe mir das schon ausgiebig gedacht. Das sind EU, das sind, ja, viel zu viele, merke ich gerade. Aber das sind die EU-Normen, da verhält man ja die Europäische Union, um sowas festzulegen, dass man dieses Loch reinmachen muss, sonst kriegen die diesen Stempel nicht, diesen europäischen Spendel. Nee, ich meine, das ist doch total, also jetzt gerade, ich will nicht wissen, auf wie vielen Bildern ich auch bin, im Hintergrund so, bei Grossevents oder sowas. Ich bin auf so vielen Fotos in meinem Leben sicher gewesen. Gut, ich glaube, Grossevents sind ja sogar, wenn du da einfaches Publikum fotografierst oder so, das ist... Ja, ist ja eigentlich kein Problem, außer es gibt irgendwann mal von Google so eine Fotoerkennung.ung. Und dann wird es problematisch, finde ich. Weil dann kannst du immer den Namen eingeben, du bist auf sämtlichen Fotos irgendwo in New York, am Times Square oder so, bist dackelig im Hintergrund rum oder sowas. Das will man ja dann auch nicht. Es gibt aber auch einen Fall, den finde ich fantastisch, grossartig, weil er unsere beiden, die beiden Dinge, die wir lieben, zusammenbringt, nämlich Comedy und Mordermittlungen. Perfekt fusioniert diese Geschichte in sich zusammen, und zwar war da ein Mann angeklagt wegen Mord, und er hatte irgendwie kein fünftiges Alibi, das konnte niemand bezeugen, und tatsächlich konnte sein Alibi damit bewiesen werden, dass er im Hintergrund bei ungenutzten Aufnahmen von Kirby Enthusiasm zu sehen war. Das stimmt, tatsächlich k kenne ich die Geschichte hier sogar. Das ist so grossartig, dass man einfach sagt. Und Larry David war auch super stolz darauf. Ja, das war so ein Baseballspiel, glaube ich, wo die gedreht haben, wo er im Hintergrund war und wo dann man anscheinend noch mal in das Material geschaut hat, weil da irgendjemand der Anwalt muss gemerkt haben, Moment mal, die Folge, weil er war nicht mal in der Folge drin, sondern in dem unbenutzten Material des Kamerateams. Das heißt, irgendjemand muss gecheckt haben, okay, die haben an dem Tag gedreht, wo mein Mandant behauptet, da zu sein. Dann schreibe ich die Produktionsfirma an, kann ich ihr unbenutztes Material anschauen, schaut sich das an stundenlang und sieht seinen Mandanten und gewinnt den Fall. Das war eine Dokumentationsreihe auf Netflix, nämlich eine True-Crime-Dokumentationsreihe, meine ich. Und das war eine Folge. Der Typ, der bei Curb Your Enthusiness einmal das Bild gelaufen ist hinten, weil er Chicken Wings gekauft hat oder sowas. Der hat nämlich aufgestanden, hat sich Chicken Wings wiedergekommen und das sieht man in dem Material. Ja, stimmt. Und die haben Larry David interviewt und einen Cutter. Und dann so freigesprochen. Bam, bam, bam, badadadam, badadam, badadam, badadam. Dafür ist jetzt das Orchester gekommen. Curb your prison sentence. Das ist eigentlich eine Wehrgeschichte. Grossartig. Das ist wirklich toll. Aber wie man da die Reihe an Ereignissen war, bis man gecheckt hat, das müssen wir jetzt machen, um den Fall zu lösen. Eigentlich haben Anwälte, man denkt, also Anwalt, es ist bei mir immer hängt zwischen super ultra langweiliges
Jura, Studium und hunderttausend
Paragraphen, aber halt auch so eine Art
Superheld, so irgendwie
total kreative Beweisführung, dann da noch mal
reingehen und dann den Mandanten freihauen.
Aber hatten, ja, ja, aber so geht es mir
bei jedem Job. Ich denke, bei jedem Job
erstmal, der ist total ultra langweilig,
aber immer wenn man, wenn ich mit diesem Job im fiktionalen Kosmos konfrontiert bin, ist es halt geil, weil du ja auch nur die überspitzten oder tollen, besonderen Fälle im Fiktionalen mitbekommst, wie zum Beispiel sowas, oder sei es jetzt bei True Crime Dokumentation, dann wirklich, kriegst du die besonderen Fälle irgendwie vorgeführt. Und dann denke ich mir, alle Sachen, die man dann so sieht, ich finde eigentlich alle Berufe auf so einer Oberfläche sind eben toll, weil man die halt alle kennt, nur aus so speziellen Fällen.
Und bei mir ist es auch immer wirklich so, also ich bin da super anfällig dafür, dass wenn ich irgendwie einen Film sehe über einen Hacker, ich mir wirklich danach so C++ Basics und Tutorial Video angucke und mir denke ich so, ich werde jetzt Hacker.
Ja und ich denke mir, wirst du nicht und nach zwei Tagen ist die Flamme wieder aus. Aber ich denke mir, das macht eigentlich einen coolen Film aus, wenn man Bock hat, das zu sein, was da gezeigt wird. Außer es geht um Drogen, die da natürlich, das ist natürlich... Meinst du, deine Serie hat Leute dazu motiviert, Drogen zu verkaufen? Ist eine Frage, mit der hast du dich bestimmt schon aufbeschäftigt. Ja, ich glaube schon, dass ich glaube, wir damit auseinandergesetzt haben. Ich weiß aber nicht, naja, das sind halt so, das war das Ergebnis seiner Auseinandersetzung. Nee, ich glaube schon, man hat auch ein paar Artikel gelesen danach und lustigerweise ist ein Jugendlicher aufgeflogen und dessen Zimmer sah genauso aus wie das Zimmer von unserer Rolle Lenny.
Ah, exakt das gleiche Zimmer, wirklich. und dessen Zimmer sah genau so aus wie das Zimmer von unserer Rolle Lenny.
Ah, okay.
Exakt das gleiche Zimmer.
Ja.
Wirklich, es war wirklich erschreckend.
Es war, als hätten die in unserem Set ein Vorbilder gemacht.
Ja, und die Set-Designer so High-Five.
Ja, ja, schon geil, das ist schon ganz cool gewesen.
Wobei, na ja, na ja, na ja, zitiert mich da jetzt nicht im Tagesspiel oder so,
oder in New York Times, das wäre noch schlimmer.
Ja, könnte schon sein. Aber neue Funktionen gibt es, wo wir gerade bei Bilderkennung waren, das neue Betriebssystem von Apple und Google Android-Phones haben das meine ich auch. Das ist glaube ich was anderes, oder? Android und Google? Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Jedenfalls, die meisten Tennis haben mittlerweile die meisten modernen Smartphones. Du kannst bei Fotos, in der Fotogalerie ein Herz und Suchfeldfeld, kannst auf die Lupe drücken und kannst oben etwas eingeben, die Tennisschläger und dann kommen alle Tennisschlägerfotos, die du jemals hattest. So, und jetzt nehmt das Handy eures Freundes und gebt mal Penis ein, nur mal so, oder eurer Freunde. Mal gucken, was man so findet. Nein, aber das ist wirklich spannend und man kann wirklich, das ist eigentlich ein cooles Spiel, finde ich, für so eine Talkshow oder so eine Late-Night-Show, dass zwei Prominente das machen und dann muss man vor der Kamera live das eingeben und muss vorher schätzen, wie viele Fotos kommen. Ja, genau, oder so mit welchem Begriff kriegt man die meisten gefundenen Bilder oder sowas.
Ja, genau. Hier ist ein bisschen Tennis. Tennis. Tennis hat vier und es sind vier Tennisbilder. Aber von deinen gemachten Fotos. Von meinen gemachten Fotos, ja. Du siehst hier vier Tennisbilder, einmal bei den Gary Viver Open war ich mal. Das ist ja krass. Vor allem ist es ja nicht mein Tennis-Schläger, sondern es ist ein Tennis-Feld. Hier in Cannes haben wir gespielt, Tennis gespielt, nochmal Cannes und nochmal Cannes. Gib mal Florentin ein. Ja, Florentin Will, hat er erkannt? 158 Fotos von dir. Da bin ich jetzt wirklich sehr gespannt. So, und du bist auf jedem Foto. Krass. Wahnsinn, ne? Ja, okay, gut, ich glaube, Gesichtserkennung ist tatsächlich noch relativ Auch weil ich dich ja... Jetzt gib mal Penis ein. Oh, da ist er sehr selbstbewusst, da weiß er genau, er hat seine Hausaufgaben gemacht. Keine Treffer, na Mensch. Ich glaube, es geht nicht. Ich glaube, das ist kein Begriff, der akzeptiert wird, weil wegen Jugendschutz oder sowas. Ja? Ja, da sind eine Million Penis-Fotos in einer Fotoroll. Machen wir uns das vor. Ein ganz grosses. Ein Riesenbild. Ein riesiges Foto. So, das ist es einfach. Nee, aber das ist wirklich spannend. Ich kann das nicht, ich habe das nicht gecheckt. Man kann sogar Herbst eingeben. Du kannst Fotos, Personen, Orte. Das ist auch klar. Du kannst auch Köln eingeben und dann kriegst du alle Fotos, die aus Köln gemacht wurden. Krass. Fantastisch. Es gibt ja auch diese Webseite, ich glaube, this is not a real person heisst sie oder so, wo ein Gesicht generiert wird von einem Menschen, der nicht existiert. Das ist einfach ein... This person does not exist. Ah ja, genau. Das ist schon verrückt. Vor allem, man erkennt es nicht einfach. Du erkennst es nicht, nee. Es werden Leute von einer Artificial Intelligence zusammengesetzt und du weisst nicht danach, was stimmt. Das gibt es auch mit und das Lustigste daran ist, dass manchmal Katzen entstehen. Was das, was fantastisch ist. Es gibt auch übrigens dieses Car, das nicht existiert, da werden Autos zusammengestellt und so. Also es gibt mittlerweile von vielen Dingen und teilweise in all diesen Dingen sind manchmal Katzen. Entweder im Gesicht oder auf der Motorhaube.
Echt?
Und da habe ich mich immer gefragt, warum.
Aber du meinst so ein ganzes Katzengesicht oder statt der Nase hat man dann eine Katze, sowas.
Ja, sowas. Oder in den Augen ist eine Katze oder das Gesicht ist eine Katze oder auf der Motorhaube, wenn bei this car das natürlich ist, ist eine Katze.
Und so man denkt, what, why, weil das so seltsam wirkt. Aber ich glaube, weil das Internet so 80 Prozent aus Katzenbildern besteht, denkt diese Artificial Intelligence einfach manchmal, ja, Katzen müssen die im Thing sein, hier, habt ihr eine Katze, ab und zu. Krass. Ja, aber das ist wirklich interessant, du setzt einfach die ganzen Menschen zusammen aus verschiedenen, sehr vielen Bildern, die es gespeist bekommt im Internet, das ist wirklich fantastisch. Das ist schon nicht schlecht, das heißt, immer so, schicken wir ein deiner Freundin, kannst du immer ein Bild schicken, das zumindest existiert von deiner Freundin in Kanada.
Die einzige perverse oder creepy.
Ja, du hast immer den direkten Zugang zu Creepiness. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich während der Schulzeit kurz mit dem Gedanken gespielt habe, eine Freundin zu erfinden.
Ja, und ich finde das so toll, weil
es so eine offensichtlich dumme
Idee ist und ich zum Glück die Reife
hatte, die als dumme Idee
abzulehnen, aber trotzdem mit dem Gedanken gespielt
hat so, weil ich habe tatsächlich mal in einem
Urlaub, also überhaupt nichts.
Da ist schon so ein Dungeons & Dragons Charakter-Sheet rausgenommen.
Ja, genau so. Und so geprobt.
Ja, und wo wohnt die? In
Botswano. Botswana, aus Botswana. Botswana, okay. Spannend, wo hast du den kennengelernt? Weil ich habe mal im Urlaub, da war ich irgendwie zehn oder so, wirklich kurz mit einem anderen Mädchen Kontakt gehabt, aber wirklich nur zusammen gespielt und so ganz normale Kindersachen. Und mir dann überlegt, Moment mal, da könnte ich ja behaupten, dass das meine Freundin ist, aber habe ich nie gemacht. Aber ich kann mich immer noch daran erinnern, an diese Nachdenkensicht. Du hast ja noch ein Foto von ihr, das ist, wo sie zehn Jahre alt war, egal wie du damals. So erbärmlich. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was man sich davon erhofft, einfach, weil in der Regel macht man ja sowas, um Mädchen zu imponieren, aber wenn man behauptet, man hätte eine Freundin, macht dann das ja entweder... Auch weil der gesellschaftliche Druck. Ja, das stimmt schon, aber da war
ich wirklich zehn oder so, also da war überhaupt kein Druck,
eine Freundin zu haben. Ich denke mir, Weihnachten denke ich mir das.
Also an Single-Weihnachten
habe ich mir schon oft gedacht,
einfach zu erfinden.
Fuck it. Ich habe
Freundinnen, drei Stück.
Ja, und wie heißt sie?
Nina Nono
Nuni
aus Botswana. Das ist ja ein interessanter Name aus Botswana. Zeig mal ein Foto. Hier, ist eine Katze. Oh, apropos Botswana, wollte ich auch noch sagen, ganz fantastisch. Bitte keine Katzenfoto. Du gehst auf This Person, wenn du nicht siehst, bitte keine Katzenfoto, bitte keine Katzenfoto. Wir haben ja letzte Folge darüber geredet, dass wir keine Ahnung von Afrika haben.
Keine Ahnung von Afrika. Keine Ahnung von Afrika. Unsere neue Rubrik. Keine Ahnung von Afrika. Keine Ahnung von Afrika. Wir haben keine Ahnung von Afrika. Wo ist der Niger, wo ist eine Wüste, was ist das für ein Fluss, wir haben keine Ahnung von Afrika. Wo ist der Niger, wo ist der Nil, wir wissen es nicht, keine Ahnung von Afrika. Links, rechts, riesengroßer Kontinent und zwar und passend, perfekt passend, noch bevor die Folge veröffentlicht wurde, hat mir jemand geschrieben und hat gesagt, ja, ich habe hier so einen Radiosender und ich habe kann, ich kriege den so nicht gefüllt und ich brauche Content. Kann ich nicht euren Podcast bei mir auf dem Radiosender laufen lassen? Und erst denkt man sich so, naja, okay, ja, vielleicht, kommt drauf an. Und dann habe ich ihn weitergelesen und dann stand da ja im Sendegebiet Namibia. Aber ich dachte mir, hell yes, sowas von.
Das heisst an alle unsere namibischen Ersthörer, Buenos Dias, Buenos Noches, Alemania, da ist gerade Nacht und Sommer. Vor allem, ich könnte jetzt nicht mal einen generischen afrikanischen Satz sagen, so wie Buenos Dias oder Piccolo Poco.
Ja.
Nichts.
Nee.
Das heisst Ja, nichts.
Nee, denn wir haben keine Ahnung von Afrika.
Also erstmal herzlich welcome to all our Namibian listeners who made it that far, 30 minutes into the episode.
Frage, was spricht man in Namibia?
Namibisch.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen so ein Dialekt.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen, kommt auch an Nordnamibia, Südnamibia, Nordnamibisch. Das ist halt so ein bisschen so ein Direkt. Das ist halt so ein bisschen gar.
Kommt auch an, Nord-Namibia, Süd-Namibia, Mord-Namibia.
Man weiß nicht immer, gibt es Süd-Namibia?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht immer, gibt es Süd-Namibia?
Oder hört es einfach auf?
Das stimmt schon.
Oder ist Süd-Namibia ein neues Land?
Bei Südafrika zum Beispiel, denke ich mir auch, es gibt so viele tolle Namen. Kongo, Elfenbeinküste, Botswana, Südafrika, Kenia und dann Südafrika, dann Südafrika, Westsahara, Namen gelesen von einem Tier und das Tier hieß Knoblauchkröte. Ja, Knoblauchröte. Weil es so stinkt oder weil es nur ist? Ich glaube, es sieht aus wie eine Knoblauchzehe. Wie viel Pech muss man als Tier haben? Löwe, Pelikan, Adler und die Knoblauchkröte. Al. Al, ja, drei Buchstaben, die sind besonders wertvoll. Al. Re. Ich behaupte, je distinktiv ein deutsches Wort. Weiter, weiter. Mach einfach weiter. Je spezieller das Tier, je mehr Gimmicks ein Tier hat, desto prägnanter und kürzer der Name. Ja, ja. Aber ich meine, so ein Reh hat ja wirklich gar nichts.immt. Also oder, jetzt mal von allen Tieren, also das ist wirklich so schnell schnell wir brauchen noch ein Tier, ja ja ja ja braun, vier Beine, Augen, Bär, dann einfach so fertig. Bär oder Re? Ja, es ist wirklich, naja stimmt schon. Nee, ein Bär irgendwie Honig, irgendwie keine Ahnung, kann schnell einen Berg hochlaufen. Berg, Bär. Ja, sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich merke, ruf mal nochmal an, ruf mal nochmal an. Sammelt Bären und geht auf Berge, Bär. Ich weiß ja nicht genau, was die Geschichte ist, die ich sagen soll. Wir sind zwei Journalisten von der New York Times und wir wollen eine Reportage machen übers Oktoberfest. Okay? Ja. Na klar, wieso? Minger am. Ach so.
Noch geht niemand. Dann ... Wenn ich was zur Nummer sage ...
Du bist Journalist, okay?
Wenn ich was zur Nummer sagen darf, ist es wahnsinnig unhotlineig.
Die Nummer hat sehr wenig gleiche Ziffern. If I could say something about the number, it's so awesome. Okay, I need your last name, please. That's Smithers. And Dawson, that's me. Hi, I'm his colleague. We're calling from New York for the New York Times reading a report on Oktoberfest and about Munich culture and all that. Okay, you just reached the call center, so I will just take the notice and then... Ah, okay. Yeah. Yeah, that's awesome. That's awesome. Okay, you can find our number on the internet under the New York Times. Actually, I don't see your number, so you have to give it to me so I can make a notice and they can give you give you a call back yeah it's it's it's different do you want to no it's also your
number no it's fine if you're um just just just google the new york times and then ask for names
they'll provide you just is it okay for us to ask you some questions? Ja, lass uns das beenden, das funktioniert nicht. Aber Test nicht bestanden. Ehrlich gesagt, weiss ich das nicht. Also wie genau Wie dumm wir sind, warum können wir uns in die Nummer ausdenken? Ja, das habe ich, soweit bin ich noch nicht beim Improvisieren lernen, Nummernausdenken. Ich habe ja auch so, Nummern auf englische, five, six, whatever. Ja, ich kenne zwei Nummern, das lernt man im englischen Unterricht nämlich nicht, Nummern sich ausdenken schnell. Nein, das Wichtige war ja, also erst mal, was hast du denn gelernt damals, dass du das, äh, abwimmeln, abwimmeln, aber das hat sich ja getan. Ja, stimmt. Scheiße. Das fühle ich mich schlecht. Ja, das ist... Darauf wird man in der Schule nicht vorbereitet. Donde esta la biblioteca? Si, claro, buenos papas fritas. Aber sie hat auch teilweise gelacht. Ich glaube, sie ist gecheckt. Ja, klar. Man hört es auch in unserem breiten deutschen Akzent. About Oktoberfest, Munich, Culture and Stuff. Und sowas halt. Und so was. Und weiteres. Ich hätte die Frage erwartet, wie sind Sie bei den New York Times gelandet? Kriegt man da schon einen Artikel zugesagt? Ja, mach mal über Culture and Stuff einen Artikel. Guter Journalist auf jeden Fall. Ach ja. Ja, ich würde gerne einen Artikel schreiben über Culture and Stuff. Ja gut, hat sie bestanden auf eine Art? Ja, sie hat auf eine Art bestanden auf jeden Fall. Wir hätten es eigentlich anders aufziehen müssen. Wir versuchen es nächste Woche nochmal mit der
besseren Geschichte. Ich versuche mich daran
zu erinnern, was noch auf der Liste stand.
Tante Erna auf jeden Fall, dann rufen wir jetzt Tante Erna
an. Tante Erna und The New York Times.
Aber sie hat nicht so nervös reagiert,
wie ich dachte, dass, ähm,
weil, wie hättest du damals reagiert, wenn
The New York Times angerufen hätten? Ey, als Callcenter
Agent kann dich nichts aus der Ruhe
bringen. Wenn dich dein
Chef anruft und gerade irgendwie einen Wutanfall
hat oder so, weil du bist am langen
Und Als Callcenter-Agent kann dich nichts aus der Ruhe bringen. Wenn nicht dein Chef anruft und gerade irgendwie einen Wutanfall hat oder so, weil du bist am langen Drücken, du sagst immer, ja, ich verbinde sie. Einfach so, du hast diesen Knopf, ist dir scheiße. Ehrlich gesagt, dafür... Ich sehe gerade, ihre Schicht endet bald, das heißt, der ist eh alles egal, weil wenn jemand wütend zurückruft, kriegt es der nächste ab. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ohne Scheiß, für ein Unternehmen, in dessen Meeting der Satz fiel, fuck, wir hätten es mit dem Internet machen sollen, Respekt, dass es noch existiert. Es stimmt schon, ja. Ja klar, wenn man Studenten ausbeutet, dann kommt man weit. Ich glaube, die haben wenig laufende Kosten, was das angeht. Naja. Hast du mal überlegt, die der Polizei zu sagen? Einfach mal der Polizei so hin. Naja, ich glaube, die machen nichts wirklich Illegales. Ich bin da skeptisch, weil auch sich keine Ziffer wiederholt hat in der Nummer, wo ich auch sage, wenn du ein Hotline bist, ist das eine Red Flag. Vor allem, ich sage mal so, Snowden, ich schreibe jetzt ein Buch. Ich will nicht sagen, jetzt kommt der Cash Grab, jetzt irgendwie macht er das grosse Geld, aber vielleicht wäre Whistleblower für mich auch eine Karriere, die ich mir vorstellen könnte. Was willst du erzählen? Ja, was da so abgelaufen ist in dem Call Center. Ja, was ist noch so abgelaufen? Ja, dass da teilweise die Hörer nicht desinfiziert wurden am Schichtende. Dass teilweise der Kühlschrank nicht ganz gefüllt war mit frischem Wasser. Dass da teilweise es hieß, bitte markiert eure Essen, sonst wird es weggeworfen und ich mein Essen markiert habe und es wurde trotzdem weggeworfen. Und dass obwohl man bitte nicht nur beidseitig jemanden rücken soll,
haben auch manche Kollegen einseitig gerückt.
Ja.
So.
Und jetzt muss ich fliegen. Toll.
Und ich habe einmal die New York Times verbunden,
obwohl ich sie hätte abwenden sollen.
Oh Gott, das war eine schreckliche Zeit.
Was ist dein Down, dein schlechtester Tag,
als du die New York Times dann doch angenommen hast?
Ein schlechtester Tag war, wo ich es nicht hinbekommen habe, einen Flug zu buchen für meinen Chef, wo ich sagen musste, ich schaffe es nicht.
Und dann wurdest du gefeuert?
Nee.
Was muss man bei sowas eigentlich machen, wenn man gefeuert wird?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Um gefeuert zu werden.
Keine Ahnung.
Du musst schon grob Quatsch machen, nicht rangehen vielleicht. Wobei, vielleicht nicht mal das.
Gibt es Jobs, wo du einfach alles machen kannst, wenn du bist nicht gefeuert hast? Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Top 5. Das kann schon sein, wo man so warten muss. Aber es war doch bestimmt eine gute Zeit, oder? Hast du da, was war der seltsamste Anruf? Bestimmt viele komische Anrufe. Ja, wie gesagt, also, es ist erstaunlich, weil es erdet einen auf jeden Fall. Wie oft wurde ein von uns den Hörer geatmet? Kam ab und zu vor.
Und wie gesagt, ich war in einer Anzeigenannahme. Also ich wurde angerufen und Leute diktieren mir ihre Anzeige, die dann in der Zeitung abgedruckt wird, um dann irgendwie Kontakt zu finden zu Leuten, romantischen Kontakt. Und manchmal haben Leute angerufen, um eine Polizeianzeige aufzugeben. Weisst du, die blättern durch ihre Zeitung, finden eine Seite mit Herzchen und Amor, und da steht gross eine Nummer, Anzeigenannahme und dann die Nummer, und die denken halt, wie man natürlich sofort denkt, das wird schon die Polizei sein, oder? Und rufen die an und sagen, mein Nachbar ist mir da mit seinem Wagen direkt den Zaun gefahren hier, da ist alles rum, hier zack, bis zu meinem Grill hat er sich da komplett durchgeschoben, hier zwei von den Streben liegen hier noch hinten, blablabla, wir tritten auf dem Weg da. Wie oft hast du die Anzeige angenommen? Ich habe sie immer angenommen. Natürlich. Also wenn jetzt jemand gesagt hätte, oh mein Nachbar wird gerade ausgeraubt oder so, dann nicht, aber das war immer Triviales, er hätte gesagt, ja, ja, okay, wie heißt der Nachbar, aha, aha, hat er das schon mal gemacht? Ja, okay, den schauen wir uns mal an, wiederhören. Oh, das war ein Polizist, der hat gesagt, das schauen wir uns mal an. Das sagen nur Polizisten. Ja, Justice, Law and Order. Aber kostet das nicht, eine Anzeige zu erstellen in einer Zeitung? Nee, das nicht. Du kriegst eine Mailbox, auf die Leute ihre Nachricht sprechen, und um die Mailbox abzuhören, muss man zahlen. Weil du willst natürlich hören, was Leute auf deiner Mailbox sagen. Und da kriegt man dich. Moment, ganz kurz. Bitte was? Ich will jetzt eine Anzeige in der Zeitung haben. Ich habe das jahrelang erklärt. Dann rufe ich dich an. Also du erstellst eine Zeitung. Ich habe jetzt schon drei Fragen. Du bewirfst dich bei der New York Times. So, also nein, du erstellst eine Zeitung. Wir ... Moment, ich habe jetzt schon drei Fragen. Du bewirfst dich bei der New York Times. So, also nein, du erstellst eine Anzeige. Ja, ich möchte gerne. Ich habe eine alte Blume, die brauche ich nicht mehr. Nein, es geht um Kontaktanzeigen. Ach so, ich suche eine Frau. Genau, ich gebe dir einen Anrufbeantworter Platz. So, wenn Leute jetzt anrufen und deine Nummer wählen, die bei dir in der Anzeige steht, dann sprechen sie auf diesen Anrufbeantworter. Hallo, hier ist die Monika, ich habe deine Anzeige gelesen, hättest du dich vielleicht mal lustig zu treffen, hier ist meine Handynummer. Und ich bezahle pro Anruf, Mailbox abhören. Richtig, du rufst jetzt wiederum diesen Anrufbeantworter an und diese Nummer ist sehr teuer.
Dadurch verdient man Geld. Und dich haben wir gerade angerufen, um über die New York Times über das Oktoberfest zu schreiben. Das war die schlechteste Ausrede aller Zeiten. Da gibt es verschiedene Abteilungen wahrscheinlich. Vor allem, das eigentliche Geld fließt ja durch, du kriegst auf deinem Anrufbeantworter einen Begrüßungstext. Also jede Dame, die sich für dich interessiert, ruft deinen Anrufbeantworter an und hört erstmal deinen Begrüßungstext und kann dann erst die Nachricht sagen. Das heißt, Nina muss mindestens so lange am Apparat bleiben, bis deine Message vorbei ist. Das heißt, die müssen alle meine einstündige Kurzgeschichte lesen, hören, die ich vorlese. Unsere Aufgabe war es, die Leute zu motivieren, natürlich einen möglichst langen Begrüßungstext zu machen, indem wir sagen, cash, cash, cash, cash, cash, cash, cash, cash, cash. Genau, so, und dann sagen wir nämlich immer, ja, je mehr sie sagen, desto mehr Leute rufen an, das Bullshit ist. Je mehr wissen die ja auch über sie. Genau, und dann haben wir so nur zehn Fragen, die man beantworten sollte. Oh mein Gott, ihr seid solche, oh, das ist moralisch so schwierig. Und in der Regel rufen dann die Leute einfach an und sagen nur ihre Handynummer ganz schnell und legen sofort wieder auf, damit die Person die privat anruft und sie ohne weitere Kosten weitermachen können. Aber sie müssen erst über den ganzen Scheiss sich anhören. Ja, aber eigentlich spannend, um Leuten will ich mal ein Drehbuch, wenn jemand zuhört, diese Kurzgeschichte bin ich mal verfasst.
Und dann liest man es vor.
Und es kamen so lustige Sachen auch,
weil die waren auch teilweise... Die hast du auch gehört dann immer.
Die mussten wir abhören, damit da nichts
Verwerfliches drauf ist. Die mussten wir erst
freigeben und so. Und
bei einem war es dann so, der
man hatte richtig gehört, so,
okay, ich mach das jetzt, ich mach das jetzt.
So, und dann, ja, hallo, hier ist der Peter und in dem Moment fängt seine Uhr an zu läuten. Dong, dong, dong und er, ja, ich, ja, also ich hab, ich stell mir halt eine attraktive Frau und währenddessen die ganze Zeit dong und wirklich wie so eine, ah, also kein falsches Möglichen Moment und genau in dem Moment, in dem die Uhr aufhört, hört er auch eher auf, ja, ruf mich an.
Nein, nein.
Und wir mussten es ja abhören alles und das war großartig.
Aber er war, du hast ja ausgestellt, ein Uhrenmacher. Das kann auch sein, ja, oder wohnt in der Kirche, so quasi modomässig. Ich wohne ganz oben im Turm.
Oh nein, die Glocke geht schon wieder.
Die Raben, die Raben, roch, ich muss auflegen.
Ja, der klang nett, oder? Da lasse ich meine Nummer da. Ja, spannend. Du hast ein Spannendes. Du hast gelebt, oder? Du hast mal richtig gelebt. Ich habe richtig gelebt. Und dann immer schön, aber wir hatten, das Tolle an dem Callcenter war, dass ganz viele verschiedene Geschäftsmodelle da zusammengelaufen sind. Also verschiedene Illegale an der Grenze zu moralischen Verhandlungen, finde ich. Und da gab es dann auch so Gewinnspiele und andere Sachen. Und aber auch so technischen Support für irgendeine Receiverbox. Und da hat nie jemand angerufen. Und kurz beim Einlernen haben wir gesagt, ja, das sind so die drei häufigsten Probleme, aber realistischerweise hätten wir niemandem helfen können.
Und da habe ich oft die Leute dann mit anderen Leuten verbunden, die angerufen haben und dann haben die gesagt so, ja, bleiben Sie kurz in der Leitung, Schleife. Und dann hat jemand anders angerufen und dann habe ich die miteinander verbunden, so dass die miteinander reden. Vollkommene Verwirrung, weil ich irgendwann so gut war mit diesem Telefon und Leute halten konnte und miteinander verbinden konnte.
Auch drei Leute miteinander verbinden.
Drei Leute, ich konnte drei Leute miteinander verbinden, ohne dass ich selber im Call war.
Ich wollte nur fragen, wie der Receiverbox.
Ich wollte eine Anzeige aufgeben.
Haben Sie mich jetzt angerufen?
Bernd?
Wollen Sie mich kennenlernen?
Hallo?
Nee, ich habe Sie angerufen.
Es war, es war lächerlich.
Sehr gut. Ja, es war so ein bisschen Flausen im Kopf.
Zeit, ne?
Wie lange hast du Flausen? Das ist der neue Film von Til Schweiger. Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Poststelle. Die Poststelle. Und manchmal hatte ich Kontakt mit den Leuten aus der Poststelle und das waren also trostlose Gestalten, die wirklich den ganzen Tag an so einer Briefmaschine sitzen mussten und wo, kennst du diese Szene, wo Bart irgendwie so hundert Umschläge befeuchten muss mit seiner Zunge und völlig am Ende ist und so waren die auch und niemand wusste, was genau da vor sich geht, aber die waren immer so fertig. Ob da auch mal der Satz gefallen ist, wir hätten mit diesenände ich auch so, ja, ich würde auch gerne mal im Kreuzhinter sein, beim Fenster. Aber waren die auch klischeehaft im Keller untergebracht? Die Postkette aus dem Keller. Nee, weil wirklich so ganz in der Ecke. Im Eulen-Turm. In der Eulenwarte. Die waren halt direkt neben der Glocke. So und dann halt alle Stunde, boong, boong. Bei dem Taubenschlag, da liegen die Leichen. Es war ganz merkwürdig. Kann gut sein, dass wir die Hälfte dieser Folge rausschneiden müssen, weil ich das alles nicht sagen darf, aber insgesamt war es eine gute Zeit. Man muss einfach mal einen Tricksjob machen, einfach mal so. Ich meine, ich habe ganz wenig davon gemacht, von daher ich bin ja froh, also ich glaube, dass es nicht körperlich sein muss. Ich glaube, Callcenter ist okay, da hast du ja die Schichten. Es klingt nach echt einem perfekten Studentenjob, ehrlich gesagt. Du wirst, glaube ich, auch normal bezahlt. Ist ja allgemein gedormt. Halt Mindestlohn, aber teilweise habe ich mir auch was zu essen gekauft. Da dachte ich mir, ich habe jetzt eine vier Stunden Schicht, dann hole ich mir so eine rote Grütze und ein Baguette und dann vielleicht Salami dazu und ein bisschen Schinken und Butter. Und einmal habe ich tatsächlich auch ausgerechnet und habe gesagt, okay, ich habe mir an Essen für diese vier Stunden und habe ich mehr, als ich in diesen vier Stunden verdiene. Das Konzept von Arbeitskraft habe ich noch nicht ganz verstanden. Ich glaube nämlich doch, weil alleine zu Hause hättest du aus Langeweile noch mehr gegessen und nichts verdient. Ja, das stimmt schon. Wahrscheinlich schon. Ja, stimmt schon. Nee, aber genau, das vermisse ich so ein bisschen, dass ich diese Zeit nicht durchgemacht habe. Dass du direkt mit geerbt hast und direkt den Lottogewinn geerbt hast. Genau. Und dann direkt im Rolls Royce. Ja, wobei ich hatte auch ein paar weirde Jobs. Ich war dann einmal in der Anwaltskanzlei kurz als Praktikant. Da wusste ich noch nicht, ob ich vielleicht Anwalt werden wollte. Und dann habe ich in meinen Schulferien gearbeitet. Ich habe plötzlich alle Schulferien immer gearbeitet. Ich fand das immer cool. Du warst in einer Rock'n'Roll-Band. War ich auch? Ja, Rock'n'Roll. Nee, aber das war ja damals unser, der Punk unserer Generation war ja einen schönen Job. Deine Generation, würde ich gerne mal verstehen. Ja, und dann tatsächlich war ich dann in der Anwaltkanzlei, wo ich dann einfach die Nachnamen von Freunden gegoogelt habe, eingegeben habe im System, um herauszufinden, ob die mal was damit zu tun hatten, mit Fällen. Und es ist halt super indiskret gewesen. Und hast du was gefunden? Ja, ganz wirklich? Ja, tatsächlich habe ich von ein paar Schulfreunden dann was gefunden. Aber das habe ich natürlich nicht erzählt, weil dann, ich glaube, dann wäre ich schon in Schwierigkeiten gekommen, beziehungsweise die Anwaltskanzlei wäre in Schwierigkeiten gekommen. Oder du kommst jetzt noch in Schwierigkeiten. Oder ich komme jetzt, weil ich das sage. Du, wir haben Polizistinnen, die diesen Podcast hören, ist dir schon klar, wenn ihr bald verhaftet. Aber das war echt, da dachte ich mir, okay, das System ist broken. Das habe ich gemacht und ich habe, du bist broken, du bist das Problem im System. Aber das sagt man noch mal machen, lachen, probieren wir das mal aus und dann schützt man, man denkt, dass man wirklich auf was stösst. Und das andere Mal habe ich im Labor gearbeitet, was spannender klingt, als es ist, weil ... Also Kleber, ne? Nee, Sonnencreme. Ach ja, Sonnencreme. Ich musste herausfinden, ob das abfärbt, ob die Flaschen auf das Produkt, auf die weisse Sonnencreme abfärben. Dann geht man in so riesige Kühlräume und muss sich verschiedene Kartons hervorholen. Und so dann sind die verschieden nummeriert, mit verschiedenen Farben und haben verschiedene Sprühköpfe und so. Man muss es dann 20 Mal betätigen und muss dann das Produkt, was da rausfließt, muss man dann bewerten. Wie eingetrocknet es ist, wie sie sich verfärbt hat und so weiter. Und das war
mega entspannt, das war wirklich ein ganz toller Job.
Für dich, der das erste Mal
unabfährt und sofort einen riesen Sonnenbrand kriegt.
Nee, ja eben nicht,
weil ich halt, weil ich halt, du hast
einen ordentlichen Sonnenbrand bekommen. Das stimmt,
aber in der Zeit, wo ich da gearbeitet habe,
war ich halt, war ich immun, war ich immun,
du bist so wie Umelix, der in die Sonnencreme-Topf
gefallen ist, wenn du den Rest des Lebens immer immun war. Und dann dachte ich auch, ich muss nie wieder Sonnencreme in meinem Leben benutzen. Tja, weit gefehlt. Jetzt habe ich Hautkrebs. Schade, in diesem Sinne. Schade. Wollen wir noch, wir können ja mal so einen Podcast-UFO-On-Tour machen, dass wir mal irgendwie so im Zoo arbeiten oder so und wir noch mal so richtig Hand anlegen. Wir müssen uns echt was überlegen. Wir brauchen wirklich mal so einen Knochenjob. Wir machen das jetzt schon, 188 Folgen, 188. Und deswegen finde ich, muss man da auch mal ein bisschen was überlegen, im Sinne von neue Rubriken, Special-Folgen, mal sowas wie Live-Folgen. Mehr Telefon-Pranks. Mehr Telefon-Pranks, die immer gut funktionieren. Das war wirklich ein Highlight, diese Folge, Wow, der Prank hat wirklich gut funktioniert.
Ich finde das ganz gut, im Zoo, Heissluftballon, Zeppelin, mir fallen vor allem fliegende Objekte ein, aber das, lass uns da mal brainstormen und dann machen wir mal spezielle Folgen.
Ich finde das im Zoo sehr gut.
Im Heissluftballon finde ich auch gut, ich glaube, da hatten wir schon sogar ein sehr konkretes Angebot, aber der wurde dann glaube ich irgendwie... Ist dann abgestürzt, weggepustet.
Sehr langsam abgestürzt. Nein!ustet sehr langsam abgestürzt nein hieß frein steigen ja lustige ist ein guppel habe ich aber mal erzählt bei einer live folge hat das mal gemacht und der ist dann der ist dann gelandet und dann landet man halt unsanft relativ und dann geht der ballon geht ein und land das sieht dann immer sieht immer ein bisschen so aus als ob das nicht funktioniert hat die landung und es kommen wohl immer und da kam ein typ an hat gesagt alles gut aufgeregt der typ kam an alles gut ich habe hier mit dem Wagen abgestellt habe ich hier abgesehen dass sie abgestürzt sind und dann mein Kumpel war dann so super auch super nervös manös, man, nein, nein, alles gut, beugen Sie sich, alles gut. Und der Ballonführer war so, nee, war super abgeklärt und es hat sich nämlich herausgestellt, dass immer Leute angelaufen kommen, weil sie denken, dass Ballons abstürzen, weil Landungen immer super unsammt sind. Was nicht für den Piloten spricht und ein bisschen an seiner Würde kratzt, dass immer wenn er landet, die Feuerwehr kommt und ihn anspritzt direkt.
Ist immer so. Ist bei allen Ballonfahrern so, dass immer Leute kommen und sagen, man landet ja auch immer mitten in irgendeinem Feld.
Wenn man da ein bisschen zu eitel ist und seine Flugkünste ernst nimmt, dann glaube ich, ist das ein harter Job.
Warum? Wie war die sanfteste Landung seit zehn Jahren?
Hier, wir haben schon einen Krankenwagen da, legen Sie sich hin, legen Sie sich hin.
Das ist alles gut. Das war für unsere Verhältnisse eine sanfte Landung. Ja, ich mache einen Flugschein, habe ich mir überlegt. Du wolltest letztens erst einen Wasserschein machen, jetzt einen Flugschein. Entscheide dich für dein Element. Leg jetzt dein Element fest. Mehr Luft als Wasser gibt. Feuerschein, Wasserschein oder Luftschein. Ein von drei. Du kannst nicht alle machen.
Erdschein? Erdschein
gibt's nicht. Es gibt nicht diese Bohrer.
Ich habe auch lange recherchiert.
Ich dachte, es gibt so unterirdische
U-Boote, die so einen Bohrer vorne dran haben.
Existieren nicht. Den Fehler spare ich dir.
Sonnenschein. Sonne ist
kein Element.
Pflanz. Nein, Pflanze.
Wir sind ja Kampfscheinen. Psycho. Funktioniert nicht. Nein, machen Wasserscheinen, dann ist gut. Wasser passt besser zu dir. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ein Wassermensch bin. Du bist so ein nautischer Typ. Es gibt wenig Wasser. Oh, das ist eine spannende Frage übrigens. Nee, ist nicht so spannend. Wie viel Wasser gibt es auf der Erde? Recht viel. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir müssen euch beschäftigen da draußen. Ich habe so viele Mails auch geschickt zum Thema
und da dachte ich mir wirklich,
oh Leute, lass uns mal alle
irgendwie, wir als Community,
gemeinsam an unserem Leben arbeiten.
Ja, und lass uns aufarbeiten.
Es haben so viele Leute geschrieben,
zu meiner dusselig
in den Raum gestellten, nicht so ganz ernst gemeinten Frage,
wie soll das funktionieren mit den Schienen,
dass die immer gleich breit sind. Und ich habe so viele Artikel bekommen und so viele Berechnungen und Zeichnungen, dass es Kegelsinn, die sich da so ein bisschen anpassen. Wo man dann wirklich sagt, Leute, das ist, also wenn ihr darauf eine Antwort habt. Aber auf der anderen Seite versetzt sich mal in die andere Person, die ihr Leben lang Bahngleise recherchiert und lernt und alles weiss über Bahngleise. Weil ich faktastisch mal einmal diesen Funfact gelesen habe.
Ja, und du weißt alles über Bahngleise.
Und auf jeder Party wirst du abgeschmettert mit
es interessiert mich nicht, deine scheiß Bahngleise zu wissen.
Und jetzt hat man mal eine Chance.
Und du hast immer diesen Satz, es ist kegelförmig im Kopf.
Ja, ja, genau.
Du bist bereit.
Wenn du fragst, wie heißt denn eigentlich dieses Land, es ist kegelförmig.
Nein, sorry, nein, sorry.
Und irgendwann passt es mal.
Du hast diesen Satz im Kopf und du hast die Mail schon geschrieben und du musst nur noch das Zentrale als Podcastsrufe eingeben und dann hast du es.
Es gibt tatsächlich erstaunlich viele so Ein-Fuck-Menschen, die haben wie so einen Pfeil auf der Sehne, angespannt, so laufen die durch die Welt und die warten nur drauf, den abzufeuern, irgendwie wenn du sag wenn du sagst, so, ja, ich ernähre mich jetzt vegan. Ja, aber Fleisch ist ja auch, es kann ja auch sehr gesund sein. Okay, alles klar. Und dann, ja, aber das ist dann wirklich. Aber das ist ein vager Fakt. Ja, so, ja, Fleisch ist bewiesenermaßen auch sehr gesund. Kleiner Tipp, okay, euer Funfact, wenn ihr einer von diesen einen Funfact Menschen seid.
Fahrt in den Wald und schreit in den Wald und habt ihn dann raus und dann passt.
Wenn ihr einen Funfact habt, dann soll er das Wort kann oder könnte nicht beurteilen, nicht beinhalten.
Worte gehen auch nicht wie vielleicht, eventuell, wahrscheinlich, nein, wenn du mich fragen würdest, nein, glaube ich, nein, nicht alles, alles nicht möglich. Versucht euren einzelnen Fakt zu kennen. Was ist dein Fakt?
Oh, ich habe eine Menge Fakt.
Die 8080s haben die ja mit so Stop-Motion-Technologie gemacht. Ja, ich bräuchte ihren Namen hier für die Reservierung.
Stefan, Stefan Skywalker. Die Ewoks waren kleine Kinder. Ne, waren kleinwüchsige Kinder. Das stimmt ja. Es gibt keine kleinwüchsigen Kinder, Kinder sind immer klein. Was, die werden nicht geboren als Kinder? Kinder sind immer klein. Wie werden denn kleinwüchsige geboren? Die werden nicht als erwachsene, kleine Menschen geboren. Ne, die wachsen halt irgendwann nicht mehr. Aber die sind nicht schon klein als Kind? Ich glaube doch, dass sie ein bisschen kleiner sind, um euch zu sein. Nein, die werden ja winzig klein. Der der Wicked gespielt hat. Ja, ich glaube, so die ersten Jahre hat man safe ein Wachstum. Und dann kommt er als Kleinwüchsig oder so. Aber wie lustig ist das dann bei denen, den man für Wicked gecastet hat, dass er bis heute diese kleinen Rollen spielt. Warwick Davis, ja. Warwick Davis, ja, weil er nicht, weil er ein kleinwüchsiges Kind war. Der war damals irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, er war ganz klein, 14 oder so, als er das Wicked gespielt hat. Aber so klein war der doch nicht. Ich glaube, du musst halt kleivere Menschen... Wie hieß denn der Evoque? Es ist Wicked. Smegel. Wicked.
Wicked?
Ja.
Wicked!
Wirklich? So hieß der... Nein.
Doch.
Das ist der Film.
Ein Film heisst Wicked mit dem.
Aber der Evoque selber heisst anders.
Oh, Stefan Tietze, Star Wars-Fakten.
Oh, es gibt ganz viele Leute, die haben jetzt diesen einen Fakt angespannt, bis zum Ohrläppchen.
Sein Film hieß Willow. Willow, ja genau. Ja, er ist Wicked. Wirklich, Wicked? Wicked, W-I-C-K-E-T. Wicked, Wicked. Wow, nicht schlecht. Na gut, okay, jetzt kriegen wir wahrscheinlich ganz viele Mails zum kleinen Wixi. Er hieß aber erst Wicked in der neuen Version. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie als Kinder schon kleiner sind als andere Kinder, aber es ist ein anderes Thema. Ich behaupte auch, man muss was nicht wissen wie Wicked. Nee, muss man nicht. In den Filmen ist es doch, ach scheiße.
Nee, wir wissen genug, jetzt reicht es auch mal, jetzt geht es darum, was zu tun, zu handeln.
So.
Tut jetzt mal was.
Und ich finde, wir müssen uns alle mal vom Star Wars Universum in ein anderes Universum suchen.
Ja.
Jetzt auch, wenn ein neuer Film rauskommt und die Saga vorbei ist, der Trailer hat mich übrigens kalt gelassen.
Vielen Dank für die ganze Frage.
Ja, warum erzählst du das nicht in deinem Antenne-Alderan-Podcast?
Da hatte ich leider keine Zeit für die Folge,
um die aufzunehmen. Enttäuschend. Ich habe leider nur Angst
für einen, Zeit für einen Podcast
in der Woche.
Aber genau, und
deswegen sollten wir uns jemand anderen Franchise. Welches Universum?
Der Weisse Hai. Der Weisse Hai?
Ja, okay, gibt es glaube ich vier Teile oder so, ne?
Ja, reicht ja. Reicht.
Ganz viel Spaß, auch beim Schwimmen.
Vorsicht, immer links vor rechts,
immer aufpassen, Punkt vorstrich, links vor rechts.
Macht man einen Schein und sagt uns, was für einen Schein ich gemacht habe.
Macht man schon einen Konditorschein oder irgendwie so was,
irgendwie so einen Turnschein. Haut rein, macht's gut,
wunderschöne Woche. Eine wunderschöne Woche, viel Spaß.
Wir haben uns nächstes tut. Danke an Lothar für das Intro.
Woche wieder, macht's gut, ciao, wir heben ab und
sagen blubblubblub.